حسنا، ما أنت؟
لقد خبطت مثل هذا يا إلهي وهذا كل شيء وبعد ذلك
لقد أتيت إلى هذا المطبخ وهنا الطابق الثاني
ويوجد حقل هناك في مكان ما ويوجد قش
أبقى أقول بعض احمق
أن أشعل النار في نفسي
حسنًا، هذا ما اعتقدته، حسنًا، لأنه يوجد دخان.
ذهبت وكنت أسير مع الأطفال من المتجر إلى
أنا أسير على هذا الطريق، وأشاهد الصغير يطير
لكنه يطير، يطير، ثم ينفجر
في السماء اليمنى وبدأ سقوط ما أنا
كنت خائفة من الأطفال الذين يحملون السلاح، فكرت، من يدري؟
سوف يذهب إلى المنزل ثم يهرب هناك
ثم سقط، ويبدو أن كل شيء في هذا المجال
حسنًا، لم أكن هناك شيئًا
لم أذهب إلى هناك، ولم أر شيئًا سوى أنت
حصلت على الخوف
هذا الوضع يحدث في البلاد
اعتقدت ربما الحرب قد بدأت
الفكرة الأولى التي جاءت لي
لذلك، لأنه طوال 27 عامًا
أول مرة أرى طائرة
سمعت واحدة فقط
انفجرت كما لو أن شيئا طار
في السماء وبدأت في الانخفاض
تفريق إلى عدة قطع نعم لأنه
أنه في السماء انفجر بنقرة واحدة
صوت واحد أو صوتين
ولكن ربما كان هناك شخص ما في الشارع سمعناه
عندما كان الخريف بالفعل والآن
ذهب هذا الدخان
مدى سرعة وصول السيارة، هذا شيء
هذه
ثم بدأنا في مكافحة الحرائق وتناوب الجميع
القيادة